Today, I'll be talking about
the R Package Validation
framework, which is a
project I've been working on
for the past a little
over a year or so now,
and I'm really excited
to share with you
all what we've been working
on and the updates that
have come out of this.
So my name is lisieux.
I'm a statistical programmer.
I have a background working
in statistical genetics,
and currently, I
work at Fred Hutch
under sharp working on
HIV vaccine research
and pretty heavily involved
in the community and the CIA
or one of the Seattle
use our organizers.
I also am one of the organizers
of the Cascadia arcom
and I also run a screen, Pascal
tiebacks, where we go through
and explain how our
code works, usually
from tidey Tuesday submissions.
So you can find me
on Twitter else.
Underscore Huse.
So a common question
that any of us,
if we've ever tried to introduce
new software into the pharma
world, is it validated question.
There are always going to
be getting is it validated?
But what is validation
can mean different things
to different people.
Yes, there's an
official definition,
but it means different
things to different people.
So the as I understand it,
the definition of validation
is establishing
documentary evidence
that our software performs some
sort of process, procedure,
activity and compliance
with our specifications
with a high degree of assurance.
So in layman's terms,
we're creating documents
to prove that our software
does what we say it does.
But why do we even
care about validation?
Why is that question even asked?
Well, a lot of people
refer to the fact
that we have to validate
our software for submission.
But there's a lot of unspoken
benefits around validation
that don't always
get talked about,
such as improved quality
and safety of our code.
Because we've gone
through and checked it.
We're very confident in
the quality of the code
as well as the fact that
they'll return proper results.
It results in faster
processing because we already
have this code.
Now set up.
We can use it across multiple
projects and trust it'll work.
And then it also
promotes trust because we
perform this validation
we've gone through
and vetted it the
best to our abilities.
So we are confident.
Then when we give
it an input, it'll
give us a consistent output as
well as through an error when
things are go out of bounds.
The validation, the practice
can be a really high bar.
And there's a lot
of documents that
go into creating validation
because first, you
have to fill out a form
for specifications,
plant uses, environments.
You're going to be using it.
And then write out
some of your code
based on the specifications,
record, the function
of authorship and some
external file, potentially
an Excel file, then
get another form
to document your test cases.
Testing, testing, environment.
How you plan on
doing your testing,
then may be the last form
to show how your testing
plan is comprehensive.
That you're proving that all
your specifications are being
met through your testing plan.
Have a third party come through
and manually evaluate your test
and get screenshots for results.
And then you have to
review your documentation
and combine it into a final
validation packet for release.
But information is shared
across all of these documents,
so any time one
of them updating,
go back and update it.
And if you manually
evaluated all your tests
and had to make
an update, you're
going to have to go
through rerun everything.
So it's incredibly inefficient.
And at any time.
It can feel like game over
because you're just redoing
your work over and over again.
But today, I want to
tell you the validation
and can be best friends,
they can work together
to provide a
validation framework,
such that we can achieve
all the goals of validation
without the as much
additional stress and work
that can be involved with that.
Using a combination
of R Markdown test
that and our oxygen
to, we can essentially
make validation push
button for validation.
And generate a document that
looks like this, where we're
able to capture a place
for signatures for everyone
that's been involved
with the project,
we're able to have information
about the environment in which
we performed our validation and
record, who wrote what pieces
of the project, the specs,
the functions, the test
cases, the code,
as well as share
what the coverage is between
our specs and our test cases.
And finally record all
of our content here,
including our test
results, all at
the click of a button without
having to redo as much work.
And this is the R Package
Validation framework,
so there's five key elements
to the framework that
is recording your specs,
writing your code,
recording your test cases,
writing your test code.
And finally generating
the documentation.
The advantage of using
this framework is,
well, it's integrated into the
arcoxia development process.
It goes it takes you from the
beginning of the ideation of I
want to create a
package all the way
through the process to creating
a package that now you've
validated.
It's native to our programmers.
It lives.
This framework lives
within the package itself.
So you don't have to leave your
R package environment in order
to form your validation or have
all the documents in there.
It allows for
iterative development
because we don't
have docs living
across multiple locations.
It it allows us to update pieces
without having to make sure
that we've updated the five
different other documents
with that piece of information.
It's reusable and extensible
because it's reliant on code.
We're able to just
rerun things and make
sure it'll just run and work.
And it's extensible.
If you want to move
pieces out of your package
into more utility
focused package,
you can totally do that.
And just copy out your
test cases and specs
and whatnot into
that new package.
And you don't have to be putting
in a whole new round of effort
into doing the.
They're going to start
at the beginning, which
is specifications now,
specifications define
the expectations of a package.
So you kind of think of
that as like the blueprints
for your package.
So it's really defining what
is the goal of your package?
A good specification
is it is going to have
several different elements.
It's like, what will
the thing be doing?
What are the expected inputs?
What are the expected outputs?
What are warnings or errors
that should be triggered when
things like letting us
know, letting the user
know when things are going
out of bounds, but critically,
a specification will not
rely on external knowledge.
You can assume that
there's basic knowledge
in the programmer
side of things,
but do not assume that they
have contextual knowledge
around the statistics
or the process.
You may be trying to
create into your package.
So if I were to be
writing a specification
for my presentation
today, I'll say
my presentation will cover the
contents of my team's approach
to validation.
It'll be roughly 15
to 20 minutes long.
And it'll be entertaining.
Now, when I go to convert
that into a specification file
that I'd see it
into my package, it
needs to have these
several different pieces.
First, it needs to
be machine readable
because we're going to need to
be able to read that later on.
It's going to need
to be independent.
So we don't want to have
multiple specification
files that linked
back to one another
because I can create
code dependencies
and make it difficult
to separate pieces out
and then close
proximity to the task.
So we want to have it
saved within R package.
So that it lives where
the programmers are
doing their work.
When we're documenting
our specifications,
other than the
actual specifications
themselves, we really want
to be capturing information
such as who wrote
those specifications
and when it was written.
So if I were to be taking the
specification that are earlier
and converting it into
what I'd be using,
they are Package
Validation framework.
I would use something like this.
And it's written
in Markdown where
we have I have a
header at the very top
there where I have the section
where I wrote that spec
and I wrote it on this date.
My specifications
are my presentation
will clearly explain the
validation procedure.
It'll be 15 to 20 minutes long.
And it'll be entertaining.
And I'll measure that by
causing at least three people
to laugh and optionally spec
one play for fame, glamour
and maybe start as
branded success reaching.
We'll see.
All right.
So let's get down to business.
We have our specs.
It's code development
time, the piece
we've all been waiting for.
And don't worry, I'm not
going to sit here and tell you
how to write code.
I'm going to trust
that you're going
to be following good programming
practices, everything
around that.
However, what I am
going to talk about
is documenting your
code for validation.
And what we want to
be capturing around.
That is who wrote the
code when they wrote it
and making sure to update the
documentation of ownership
whenever the code gets updated.
And the way we're going
to go about doing that
is using oxygen tanks.
So if you're writing your code
according to good programming
practices, you're going
to be adding documentation
around that.
And a lot of folks are going
to use oxygen to do so.
So we suggest using
these two oxygen tanks
at section last, updated by.
And at section last updated date
to capture this information.
And the value of
doing this is it
provides close
proximity to the task.
Whoever is actually working
on the function at that time
doesn't have to go
to an external Word
or document to make
sure to update update
if this function here.
And this is when I did it.
No, it's actually right
there with the function.
So it makes it simple to do.
It's a natural extension of
the documentation already being
performed as we're
already using oxygen, too.
And an added benefit is
it adds documentation
that the functions itself
because of some oxygen
or oxygen tank,
it's actually when
you compile your documentation,
it'll be added in there.
So this is a simple
function that I
wrote a joke where you have
a punch line and a setup,
but really what we care about is
these two rocket attacks here.
So I was the one that
wrote this function.
And this is when I wrote it.
And it's a very simple function.
But say, Joe King came through
and updated my joke to make it.
So that had any parameter.
So the user could
specify how long
it waited before it
delivered the punch line.
Well, Joe updated that.
He updated his
normal wroxton tags,
but then he also updated the
updated by end date to Joe
and when he updated it.
And now that we know that that's
in there, when he regenerates
the documentation the
health pages have,
who wrote that function.
And when they updated it.
So you are now the owner
of that that function
for validation purposes.
Right so now we're going
to Connect the dots.
So we have our code.
And we have our specs.
But we need to prove
that we've met our specs.
And the way we do that
is through test cases.
The test cases prove what you
wanted to do to what you did.
Now, a single test case can
satisfy multiple specifications
if it's covering a
lot of the functions
that you're going
to be using, stuff
like that, you can prove that
you've met your specifications.
However, every
single specification
must be satisfied by at least
one test case and the risk
of a specification
drives then the level
of testing performance,
the number of times
you'll be testing that
function with new inputs.
Now, a good test case
will share, which
specifications are being met.
And how they're being met,
detail the required set up.
So if there's any data
that need to be loading in,
if there's any
environment, variables
need to be setting
that little detail.
This is what you
need to be doing.
It'll be it's a
recipe, really, for how
to get from this set up
input into the desired
output with clear
expectations for what you're
going to be testing against.
So if you're reading
in a data set,
you want to be clear to
say, rather than saying,
check the links, go check that
the length of this data set
is 34 rows.
But critically, there's
no code provided
because you want whoever is
going to be performing the test
testing to not be able to copy
and paste the code because then
you can actually test it.
When you're documenting
your test cases,
we're going to capture the same
information that we have been
who wrote the tests
and when they wrote it,
but we're also going to
capture, which specifications
are being satisfied because I
can update those tests, update.
And we can use wroxton tags.
Surprise, surprise to do that.
So at section less
updated by that section
of last updated date and at
section specification coverage.
And so if I were to be writing
a test case for my presentation
today, I have my sections.
At the top here.
So I wrote this test case.
This is what I wrote it.
And these are the test case in
which specs are being covered.
I have a setup where I
create my presentation.
Then I will go through and prove
that I met my specifications
by my first test test.
The presentation was informative
by asking my audience
that what they learned, I
will tie my presentation,
make sure it's between
15 and 20 minutes long
and test it as entertaining by
counting the number of chuckles
from the audience, which
unfortunately, I can't hear you
right now.
Hopefully you're
laughing or when
I practice it to myself,
other the number of roles
and trust me, there
were a few of them.
All right.
So now we have all
the setup here.
So now we're going to fill in
the lines with test coding.
So test coding is the
actual implementation
of the test cases in code.
We're going to be then recording
the results to prove that we've
met our specifications.
But very, very
importantly, a third party
be doing this to
somebody that was not
involved in the
writing of the package
or the writing of the test.
Cases can now go through
and perform the testing.
They could have written
the specifications,
but so the benefits of
doing this test coding
is going to help resolve
interpretation errors
in your documentation
and examples,
because this person
doesn't actually
know how to use your package.
They're able to they're going
to be using your documentation
to see how they're supposed
to be achieving the test
cases that you lay out.
And if they have any, they can
raise any questions about it,
about your documentation.
This wasn't very clear to me
because you're, as the author,
intrinsically understand
how the function is
supposed to be behaving.
This new person
doesn't know that.
So they can ask you to improve
your documentation or examples.
If the test case itself
isn't very clear,
they're going to come
to their own conclusion.
And so then it's going to fail.
And they are able to you're
able to go back and then improve
your test cases.
And the failing test case is
not necessarily a bad thing.
It just means that you need
to improve your documentation.
And then any interpretation
errors in your specifications.
If they didn't write,
their specifications
will begin once they can go
back and help improve those.
And then in general, it
helps identify improvements.
So if your code runs slowly or
if an argument is incredibly
clear, they're able
to go back and go,
hey, we were missing
this argument here.
Can you please add that in?
As I was going through
the test cases,
it didn't really make
a whole bunch of sense
to be able to have to
set it up this way.
So it really allows for
iterative improvement
before you even get
to the first release.
So we're going to use a
combination of testthat
that and surprise,
surprise or oxygen to.
We're going to
document our test.
Head with who wrote
the test code.
And when they wrote it using the
same wroxton tag plus updated
by and last updated date.
And so this is an
example of what
the test code might look like.
So we have the header
here at the top.
And so each test piece
will have its own test.
That section here, it's exactly
like any other test that.
But we have the slot
that last updated
by just her last updated date.
Here's the expectation.
The test, they have,
the code they run
and the expectations
completely like
any other test that set up.
And the reason we're using
that is a familiar framework
that's used by a ton
of packages on crack.
Right now, it's the de
facto standard basically
at this point for unit testing.
So we're going to steal that
and use it for our purposes.
It can also be run and
develop either interactively
or in batch.
So we don't have to have
somebody manually running it,
but they can manually run it as
they're building up their test.
But the real and the
big reason why we use
test that is for the reporter
objects that live within test
that.
So reporter objects are a
special live inside test
that helped track and
test each expectation
and reports,
whether they succeed
or if they do fail,
why they failed.
And that's very
important because we
need to track that for
our validation purposes.
So a standard reporter object
output kind of looks like this.
So if you've ever built a
package and Control Shift
after that unit tests
in there, you've
actually used a reporter object.
You just don't really know
because under the hood.
But what we are able
to do is we took
we execute the reporter
object, but then we
use a custom function to
extract the results for us
and make a nice table that
shows which test was run,
whether the results
were as expected
or if they were different, what
they were that was different.
And then a pass or fail.
And we can put
that into a table.
Right proof is in the pudding.
So what do we have.
So far?
We have our specifications.
We have a code, we have
a test case and our test.
But, you know, as we
said, the validation
was all about documenting
that we did all this.
And this is our
validation documentation.
So we're going to use R Markdown
to create a vignette where
we're going to record all of
the information that we created.
So far into a vignette.
We're going to have
a sign-off approval
section based on your
organizational requirement.
We're going to capture
environmental information
such as the R version and
package dependency versions
in the R Markdown
because it's dynamic.
It'll update whenever you rerun
your validation documentation
and you can also capture
any other organizational
requirements that
might have been
found in any other
documents for validation.
Then using market.
And we're going to dynamically
redone our specifications,
once again, it is very
critical that they were machine
readable, scrape the
test code for authorship,
read in the test cases and
drop those into the document,
and then execute
all the test code
and capture those results
into the tables that we saw.
And so this is
the general format
of what you might
see your package as.
Under the vignettes
folder, we're
going to have the
validation RMV, which
is going to have all
the code in set up
and recording of
the environments.
This is then going
to be the results.
Typically in the PDF.
We're going to have our
validation folder where
we have our specs are test
cases and our test code
and all the content
underneath there.
So all together.
Now So like I said, we're
going to use R to test that.
And we're oxygen to and
with our powers combined.
We're able to generate a
reproducible validation
report at the click of a button
or at the build of a package
because it lives in
the vignettes folder.
And when you build
it, you can tell
it to execute your vignettes
so you can make sure
that you don't have in R package
that has failed as validation.
And we generate this exact
same report that we had before,
but now you know where
all this came from.
We wrote in these the
signature pages here,
this validation
environment was so great.
There was generated at the
build of this document.
We pulled in all this
information about
who wrote these
specifications, who
wrote the functions, who
wrote the test cases, who
wrote the test code.
We were able to show coverage
of all the specifications
to the test cases.
And we're able to drop it all
into this document dynamically,
we don't have to manually
go through and update it
every time.
So that's the framework
where are we at now?
So currently, I'm
working on a white paper
with a team refused to describe
the framework process in more
detail, as well as
generalizing and recording
the optimal processes that would
suggest you follow when you're
using this framework.
And it's very much
under construction.
Hopefully will be coming
out later this year.
Really excited for this.
We're also working on a
valve tools, R package.
So this is going to be
based on the white paper.
It's very much in
progress, but it'll
provide tooling
that's not currently
available with use
this or DevTools
to help folks perform
their validations using
this framework.
And hopefully that'll be coming
out later this year as well.
So many Thanks to
all the folks that
have been involved with
this framework, Fred Hutch.
So we're even totally Anthony
Williams, Jimmy barthe, Rafael,
Alicia qiana and Paul
and Kate, as well as
the folks that are on the
fuse, our Package Validation
framework working group,
because you really
helped me figure out how
to expand this framework
and really make it more general.
So for more folks.
So hopefully now you understand
that validation and are
can truly live together forever.
Thank you very much for having
me talk today, our studio,
as well as for kaguya and
putting this together,
you can find more code in
this presentation at GitHub.
Dotcom bioengineers validation
RStudio underscored 2021.
Thank you so much.